also dazu muss man sagen dass die die
amerikanischen Rapper oder generell
denke ich mal viele amerikanische
Künstler extrem unterbelichtet sind das
bedeutet nicht dass sie doof sind aber
sie interessieren sich
wenig dafür was außeralb von Amerika
passiert so das gilt nicht nur für die
die die Rapper oder Musiker sondern auch
eigentlich für die Bevölkerung wenn man
bedenkt dass wenige auch wirklich wissen
wo Europa liegt od dass es Europa gibt
und ähm deswegen bin ich auch gar nicht
daran interessiert oder ich wage gar
nicht zu sagen dass mich irgendjemand
kennt in Amerika und
deswegen habe ich mich damit abgefunden
und ich habe jetzt keine aktuellen
Anfragen laufen nach Amerika aber es
gibt natürlich den ein oder anderen
Künstler mit dem würde ich gerne
arbeiten aber das ist mit mit Amerika
viel zu kompliziert also wir kennen das
auch aus dem UN Sicherheitsrat das ist
mit den nicht so einfach